Post-processing effects enable you to define the overall look and feel of your scene through
various properties and features that affect coloring, tone mapping, lighting, and more.
We use a special type of volume called a post-processing volume that can be added
to the level to access these features.
Take note, you can add multiple volumes in your level to define the look of a specific
area or layer effects for finer granular control.
So if we jump back to our scene, now real quick, I've opened the Lit Atmos In class,
and if you're following along or you didn't save, all I simply did is go up to our window,
I went to our Environment Light Mixer, click through all of our properties, and then
for our Environment Height Fog, I made sure the volumetric fog was checked.
And of course then we put them in a folder just called Environment, and you can see
all of these actors.
And then holding Ctrl L, just simply adjust your light where you want.
So I'll do something over here, and we're ready to go.
The next step that we want to do is, in this level, we already have a post-processing
volume.
Now you could click this, delete it, or I'm simply going to hide it, and now we're
back to our default.
And this is where we want to start.
I'm going to go over to our Place Actors, and I'm going to search for Post, and I'm going
to look through a post-processing volume, and go ahead and drag it into our scene.
And here we can see we have post-processing volume too.
Now by default, our post-processing volume has a shape, and we can edit the shape.
In fact, we could adjust this.
It is a brush, so we can actually adjust the individual, essentially, vertices of this,
or we can change the shape to something like a cylinder, a sphere, a capsule.
We're going to keep it as a cube.
That's absolutely fine for right now.
But what I want to make note of is that the settings that this post-processing volume
is going to change or implement, which is what's in the Details panel here, by default
is set to be only within that volume.
So the camera that we're viewing through, so if I move the camera around here, once
it enters into this space, that's when these settings will be applied.
Now for this one, we actually want the settings to be applied across our whole scene, and
ignore the shape.
So to do that, I'm going to scroll down here in the Details panel, and what we're
looking for is underneath our post-processing volume settings, we want to use Infinite Extent
Unbound.
So if we check that, and nothing's going to happen because we haven't adjusted any
settings, what this means now is it's ignoring the shape, and it's just going to apply
it across our whole scene.
That's what we want to start with.
One other pro tip that I want to mention here is, if you plan on using multiple post-processing
volumes, which is absolutely fine, I would highly recommend it, you have to ensure that
you have priority set up.
So zero is going to be our default.
So say that I want to use this base post-processing volume to just set up my exposure, maybe disable
some effects, whatever, just establish essentially a baseline, I would just keep this as zero.
I could then add another post-processing volume, and by simply checking any one of these properties,
it's going to override whatever is below that.
So by setting my priority just higher than whatever the previous ones, anything I change
will override that.
Hopefully that makes sense.
Now for this example, we just need one post-processing volume, and we're going to
start there.
All right, so with our Infinite Extent Unbound checked, I'm going to scroll back up, and
the first thing that I want to do is adjust the overall exposure of our scene.
So I'm going to do our Min and Max CV, and I'm just going to set these to one.
You notice it kind of darkens the scene a little bit.
And then our exposure compensation, I'm going to check this, and you'll notice that I can
drag this around, or we can choose a setting.
Now in this case, I know, I think it's about nine is going to be our exposure.
If that's too much, again, we can take this a little bit lower.
Something to take note of here, for those of you that are diehard camera fans and stuff.
So we are adjusting the exposure of our scene, but because we're working within a digital
medium, this is non-destructive.
There are some different things we can do, in particular with using cinematic cameras
where we can do a, you know, more filmic or camera-based exposure, but this post-processing
volume, all we're simply doing is just trying to get this to where we can see our scene,
but we absolutely can use EV stops.
We can use any of those types of parameters that we would normally to do this.
All right, hopefully that makes sense.
One of the other questions that'll probably be here is why did we choose eight for our
exposure compensation?
And really that just has to do with our directional light.
Because we created it through our environment light mixer, it brought in the directional
light with an intensity of 10 lux.
So by simply adjusting this post-processing volume, it's just going to help us again,
just to see the scene a little bit better.
All right, so I'm not going to step through every one of these settings within the post-processing
volume.
I highly recommend you just to kind of play and experiment, but there's a lot of
cool things that you can do.
For example, chromatic aberration, I can set this way high, start my offset.
You'll see that we can do a bunch of different artistic effects, again, whatever your heart
desires, feel free to.
Local exposure is another great way to get some very fine granular control.
And we, of course, have our color grading, where again, we could go in and adjust certain
properties.
And you can see here, we have our color correction controls.
If at any point you've made a change you don't like, and you just need to reset
it back to default, but you don't remember what that is, click this little loopback
arrow, and it will reset it back to default.
And I'm going to uncheck this.
And then one other thing that I want to make note of is the post-processing volume does
have some performance controls within it, as well as being able to override or specify,
for example, our global illumination or reflections.
So within the global illumination kind of roll up here, as well as reflections, you
see that we can check our method, and this will override whatever our project default
is.
In conjunction with that, you'll notice here in our Lumen global illumination, we
have the ability to bump up the quality and the performance costs of those calculations.
So if you want to control your global illumination, how it looks, how it responds in performance,
this is how you will do it through a post-processing volume within the global illumination.
And then of course, we have reflections where again, we can change this to Lumen,
None, Screen Space.
And if we expand these out, you see again, we also have some of those controls for the
quality of those calculations.
In the next video, we'll discuss how to create a post-processing material and
apply it to a post-processing volume.